[Aplausos]
[Música]
efe
la víctima
las filas de misión
a todos los trabajadores de actividades
no esenciales deberán quedarse en casa
en las próximas dos semanas
go home
país tras país la propagación del sars
coronavirus 2 está paralizado gran parte
de la economía mundial para frenar la
expansión del virus los estados están
decretando todo tipo de medidas
extraordinarias incluyendo el
confinamiento de la población en sus
casas el cierre de fronteras o la
paralización de buena parte de la
actividad comercial e industrial
evidentemente toda esta situación va a
tener unas consecuencias económicas
enormes consecuencias que por cierto
llegan incluso a la industria del fútbol
la plantilla del barça se reduce el
salario la plantilla del fc barcelona ha
confirmado este lunes que ha aceptado
una rebaja del sueldo del 70% mientras
hay estado de alarma por el coronavirus
hablamos de un panorama en el que
empezamos a encontrar los titulares como
estos el parón económico y el
confinamiento dejan 240.000 empresas al
borde de la quiebra cuatro de cada diez
empresas españolas están en pérdidas son
las más vulnerables si la congelación
del sistema productivo se alarga el
desempleo podría alcanzar el 30 por
ciento de los eeuu según james bullard
presidente de la reserva federal de san
luis y amigos ojo porque el problema que
tiene pulsar esta especie de botón
nuclear que paraliza de golpe la
actividad económica y social de un país
entero no se traduce sólo en el daño
inmediato que se produce al tema
las empresas cerradas a cal y canto sino
que tampoco tenemos ni la más remota
idea de cuánto tiempo tardaremos en
recuperarnos ni en cuáles van a ser las
consecuencias finales una vez hayamos
vencido al virus
[Música]
no nos engañemos por un lado lo más
seguro es que los gobiernos no levanten
de golpe todas las medidas
extraordinarias que han tomado sino que
todo apunta que para evitar una segunda
ola de contagios lo harán poco a poco e
incluso lo más seguro es que algunas
restricciones perduren al menos hasta
que se encuentre una vacuna o un
tratamiento eficaz y eso es exactamente
lo que ahora está ocurriendo por ejemplo
los países de asia que parecían haber
vencido al cómic 19 muchas de las
restricciones que afectan a lugares
públicos como cines restaurantes hoteles
o centros comerciales pues siguen en pie
y eso eso no es todo
[Música]
en china están restringiendo la entrada
al país y cancelando la mayor parte de
los vuelos internacionales en taiwán la
cuarentena para las personas que
regresan al país es obligatoria y
saltarse la implica multas de hasta 30
mil dólares y ojo el acceso a
extranjeros al igual que ocurre en hong
kong y singapur ha sido prácticamente
vetado por su parte en corea del sur los
extranjeros si pueden entrar pero tienen
que cumplir obligatoriamente una
cuarentena de 14 días confinados en un
apartamento o en una habitación de hotel
y vamos todo apunta a que también
veremos este tipo de medidas más
adelante en el resto del mundo
incluyendo en europa y en eeuu
[Música]
y en otras palabras que el daño sobre la
economía puede prolongarse durante
bastante más tiempo por otra parte para
muchas industrias el daño ya está hecho
y la vuelta a la normalidad la vuelta a
la normalidad les va a suponer un
esfuerzo titánico el sector del turismo
necesita de media alrededor de 19,4
meses para recuperarse de las epidemias
más incluso que los 11,5 meses
necesarios para recobrarse de ataques
terroristas
jacob a la gestor de fondos de fidelity
y por supuesto los propios gobiernos
tampoco se van a escapar de rositas si
algo hemos aprendido durante las últimas
décadas es que las crisis económicas
suelen terminar con una enorme una
gigantesca montaña de deuda pública y
esta vez pues no va a ser diferente
muchos países van a registrar durante
todo el 2020 unos agujeros
presupuestarios tan grandes que por sí
mismo podrían conducir a una nueva
crisis financiera y eso eso es
precisamente lo que explican noticias
como esta que el banco central europeo
saca su bazooka y rompe todos los
récords de compra de activos en una
semana para que os hagáis una idea el
banco central europeo ha sacado toda la
artillería pesada para impedir que las
primas de riesgo de países como españa o
italia suban hasta la estratosfera
para hacer frente a esta crisis y
facilitar que los gobiernos europeos
puedan endeudarse a tipos reducidos el 5
central europeo ha puesto en marcha un
programa de compras de deuda pública y
privada dotado de un presupuesto de 750
mil millones de euros sólo durante la
semana del 23 de marzo de 2020 el banco
central europeo compró activos por unos
39 mil millones de euros más de 40 mil
millones de dólares el mayor nivel
semanal de compras de toda su historia
en otras palabras que a pesar de lo que
se está diciendo en italia y en españa
lo cierto es que el banco central
europeo ya está rescatando a los países
europeos más afectados por esta crisis
ahora bien espera de un segundo
evidentemente la crisis no se limita al
viejo continente de hecho en el momento
de hacer este vídeo el país con más
contagios por corona viles de todo el
planeta no es otro que los eeuu
[Música]
y esto esto nos lleva a hacernos algunas
preguntas qué consecuencias está
teniendo ya la propagación del virus
cómo piensan los eeuu a enfrentarse a la
crisis que se avecina sabías que los
eeuu acaban de lanzar el mayor programa
de rescate de toda la historia atentos
un jarro de agua fría amigos amigas en
un pasado vídeo aquí en visual político
os contamos como durante semanas el
gobierno de españa' pasó olímpicamente
del coronavirus corona corona que pero
venga ya si eso no es más que una gripe
son cosas de chinos que han visto muchas
películas de ciencia ficción y se las
creen todas y así hasta que por supuesto
fue demasiado tarde para detener su
propagación pues bien algo muy pero que
muy parecido ocurrió en los eeuu atentos
[Música]
sin embargo las cosas evolucionaron de
forma muy diferente día 1 de abril de
2020 con casi 200.000 contagiados en
eeuu tiene el mayor número de casos de
todo el planeta y la tasa de crecimiento
más alta quiero que todos los
estadounidenses estén preparados para
los días difíciles que se avecinan
estamos pasando por unas semanas muy
duras
donald trump veréis para situarnos mejor
un informe del imperial college ha
determinado que si no se hubieran tomado
medidas este sars coronavirus 2 hubiera
terminado con la vida de más de 2
millones de norteamericanos
e incluso ahora tras haberse puesto en
marcha medidas como el confinamiento la
restricción de viajes y el cierre de
colegios universidades y centros de
trabajo los principales asesores
científicos de la casa blanca' estiman
que este patógeno en el mejor de los
casos va a terminar con la vida de más
de 100.000 estadounidenses y por
supuesto las consecuencias económicas ya
se están empezando a notar
a comienzos del mes de marzo está solo
hicieron falta 15 días para que las
bolsas norteamericanas registrarán el
desplome más rápido de toda su historia
en poco más de quince días el s p500 el
índice que aglutina las 500 mayores
empresas cotizadas en los eeuu cayó más
de un 30% desde máximos
por su parte firmas financieras como
goldman sachs y morgan o morgan stanley
esperan que la economía de estados
unidos caiga en recesión y registre
caídas récord del pib morgan stanley por
ejemplo espera que la economía
norteamericana sufra una contracción en
el segundo trimestre del año de entre el
24 y el 30 por ciento del pib respecto
del mismo trimestre del 2019 son cifras
nunca antes vistas
de momento los datos de desempleo
tampoco invitan al optimismo 26 de marzo
del 2020 un récord de 3,3 millones de
estadounidenses solicitaron el desempleo
la pasada semana mientras el coronavirus
daña la economía es probable que la tasa
de desempleo de los eeuu ya haya
aumentado al 5.5 por ciento un nivel que
no sabía desde el 2015 33 millones de
personas en tan sólo una semana hablamos
de una cifra de destrucción de empleo
que no tiene precedentes entre otras
cosas porque nunca antes la economía se
había parado de semejante forma
y todo esto todo esto amigos llegará un
momento en el que durante los últimos
años gracias a los tipos de interés
están bajos muchas empresas han subido
un montón de deudas hasta tal punto que
en eeuu la deuda corporativa es decir la
deuda de las empresas se encuentra en el
mayor nivel de por lo menos los últimos
40 años
y evidentemente uno de los riesgos que
existen es que si la crisis sanitaria
dura demasiado tiempo muchas empresas
van a ver caer fuertemente sus cifras de
negocio van a entrar en pérdidas y
entonces muchas podrían llegar a tener
problemas para devolver todas estas
deudas contraídas
lógicamente el daño será mayor cuanto
más se tarde en superar la crisis
sanitaria pero a día de hoy lo cierto es
que no sabemos ni cuánto tiempo va a
llevar ni tampoco cómo demonios va a ser
la recuperación si en forma de uve wml o
de cómo diantres sea
en cambio lo que sí sabemos con los
precedentes en la mano es que el riesgo
de que se produzcan daños permanentes es
alto por ejemplo se sabe que durante la
conocida como gripe española que acabó
con la vida de más de 500.000
norteamericanos las zonas más afectadas
experimentaron durante los siguientes
años una disminución relativa del empleo
la producción industrial o los activos
bancarios luego tenemos el caso de
grandes desastres naturales como el
huracán katrina que vale evidentemente
no es una epidemia pero sí es un shock
externo que puede causar efectos hasta
cierto punto similares pues mientras el
impacto del katrina la falta de reacción
hizo que el empleo se desplomara más de
un 30 por ciento y que apenas dos años
después se hubiera recuperado la mitad
de la caída en la actividad económica
en fin el caso es que durante el mes de
marzo todos los indicadores económicos
se han dado la vuelta y han comenzado a
caer con fuerza en los eeuu el consumo
la inversión las exportaciones al igual
que ha ocurrido en europa la economía
norteamericana se está parando para
tratar de contener alcohol ahora virus y
mitigar sus posibles consecuencias
la cuestión ahora es cómo evitar una
gran crisis o mejor dicho cómo lograr
superar este bache sin que los daños
económicos sean excesivamente altos
atentos
[Música]
la madre de todos los rescates
tras una tramitación rápida y casi
unánime entre republicanos y demócratas
tanto en el senado como en la cámara de
representantes el día 28 de marzo donald
trump firmó la ley que contempla el
mayor rescate de la historia de los eeuu
22 millones de dólares el 10% del pib
para hacer frente a las consecuencias
económicas de el coronavirus ninguna
política económica puede poner fin a las
dificultades de forma completa esto ni
siquiera es un paquete de estímulo es un
alivio de emergencia es un alivio de
emergencia eso es lo que es mitch
mcconnell líder de la mayoría en el
senado de los eeuu
[Música]
bilingüe del exterior es exponente del
proceso y blindado es presidente pero
pero se lo que muchos os estáis
preguntando a ver enrique exactamente a
qué va a ir destinada esta descomunal
cantidad de dinero pues vayamos por
partes
algo más de 300 mil millones de dólares
se van a destinar a enviar cheques a la
inmensa mayor parte de los ciudadanos
norteamericanos sí sí cheques en
concreto cada persona que gane menos de
75 mil dólares anuales van a recibir en
su casa un cheque de 1200 dólares y 500
dólares por niño de esta forma una
familia de cuatro miembros que ingrese
menos de 150 mil dólares anuales por
recibir a cheques por valor de 3 mil 400
dólares para compensar los daños de la
crisis si ganan más la cantidad se va
reduciendo progresivamente
y luego algo más de 200 mil millones se
destinan a ampliar el derecho a recibir
el seguro de desempleo se amplían el
número de personas que pueden
solicitarlo el tiempo durante el que se
disfruta de él y también los pagos a
recibir durante los próximos cuatro
meses por cierto apunte el rescate
también plantea que las aseguradoras
tengan que hacerse cargo de los costes
derivados de esta enfermedad así como
del coste de realizar la prueba la idea
fundamental es que las familias no
recorten sus niveles de consumo aunque
esto sea a costa del presupuesto público
wicker cheque dar después la labor su
parte para las pequeñas y medianas
empresas se abre una línea de 360 mil
millones de dólares en préstamos
participativos es decir préstamos en
condiciones favorables que parcialmente
pueden condonar se perdonarse si se
cumplen algunos requisitos como por
ejemplo mantener el número de empleados
y los pagos a proveedores para las
grandes empresas la cantidad asciende a
500 mil millones de dólares eso sí en
este caso las grandes corporaciones
deberán cumplir algunos requisitos como
por ejemplo suspender los programas de
recompra de acciones y además el proceso
será evaluado de cerca por un comité de
seguimiento
por último el plan contempla algo más de
125 mil millones para hospitales
fármacos equipamiento médico y otros 300
39 mil millones para apoyar la lucha
contra el coronavirus de los estados y
los gobiernos municipales
y estas son las principales medidas del
mayor paquete de rescate de la historia
de los eeuu el plan con el que la
administración trans espera poder
mitigar los daños causados por esta
crisis
dicho esto tal vez el mayor problema que
entraña tiene que ver con que los eeuu
pues han llegado hasta crisis sin hacer
los deberes me explico la administración
trump había proyectado para este 2020 un
déficit público de algo más de un billón
de dólares ojo un billón hispano es
decir casi un 5% del pib un agujero
gigantesco sobre todo si tenemos en
cuenta que la economía de eeuu llevaba
más de 10 años de crecimiento económico
sostenido
pues bien el caso es que ahora con este
paquete de rescate y el daño que la
crisis puede causar en las arcas
públicas el déficit se va a disparar
hasta niveles no vistos desde la segunda
guerra mundial niveles que pueden estar
fácilmente entre el 15 y el 20 por
ciento del pib
para que os hagáis una idea las
estimaciones recientes de morgan stanley
apuntan a que durante el 2020 y el 2021
que el déficit público del gobierno de
los eeuu ascenderá casi 5 billones de
dólares prácticamente el tamaño de toda
la economía de japón que es la tercera
mayor economía del planeta tras eeuu y
china o por ejemplo el equivalente
también a casi cuatro veces toda la
deuda pública española todo esto en tan
solo dos años
es decir que la deuda nacional de los
eeuu puede llegar a superar el 125 por
ciento del pib en apenas dos ejercicios
y la pregunta es cómo se va a financiar
pues amigos aquí la reserva federal va a
jugar un papel clave y ha anunciado que
va a comprar bonos de deuda pública del
gobierno como si no hubiera mañana y eso
eso es lo que explica que empiezan a
aparecer titulares como este el
coronavirus desencadena un dilema sobre
el dólar estadounidense en china a
medida que la reserva federal actúa
china es el segundo mayor tenedor
mundial de deuda del gobierno de estados
unidos con aproximadamente 1,1 billones
de dólares en bonos del tesoro de eeuu a
medida que la reserva federal de eeuu
aumenta la flexibilización monetaria y
reduce los rendimientos de los bonos
algunos analistas están preguntando si
quien debería vender sus tenencias de
deuda estadounidense estaremos ante un
punto de inflexión en la geopolítica
mundial puede acaso suponer el
coronavirus un nuevo traslado de
influencia desde occidente hasta oriente
funcionará el plan de trump para
rescatar la economía de los eeuu estas
son algunas de las preguntas clave que
faltan por responder así que si te
parece déjanos tus impresiones en los
comentarios y ya sabéis si este vídeo se
resultó interesante no olvidéis darle a
like y suscribiros a visual político por
cierto un saludo a todos los estudiantes
de nuestro colega del profesor luis
espinoza que nos han escrito desde la
universidad san francisco de quito desde
aquí un fuerte abrazo y también para
todos vosotros una vez más
gracias
bueno